ce lundi le palais des congrès de paris
accueille un débat entre deux
personnalités polémique d'un côté eric
zemmour de l'autre michel onfray le
philosophe d'abord classé à gauche et
désormais encensé par l'extrême droite
brosseau à jour l'une de ses premières
télés c'était en 1989 à 30 ans michel
onfray est prof de philo depuis six ans
le voici chez lui en train de cuisiner
il vient de sortir son premier livre le
ventre des philosophes au fur et à
mesure des lectures quand on avale
quelques oeuvres complètes pour des
travaux de l'université on a tendance à
laisser de côté des textes qui sont et
qui sont intéressants tout de même
notamment ce qui concerne la nourriture
je ne suis aperçu un jour qu'il y avait
beaucoup à dire sur le statut de la
nourriture chez des philosophes
anarchiste populiste de gauche ou encore
libertaire voilà comment michel entrée
aime se définir sur les plateaux télé
gordini vous êtes anticapitaliste
primaire
convaincu des primaires
2002 il quitte l'éducation nationale
michel onfray créé l'université
populaire de caen le principe des cours
de philosophie ouvert à tout le monde
gratuit où les profs sont bénévoles et
pas d'examen et de diplômes l'esprit
c'est la gratuité c'est le don c'est
l'espèce de circulation du savoir quand
on a quand on dispose de savoir il ya
aucun intérêt à thésauriser à garder ça
pour soir donc l'intérêt c'est le
partage cette université accroît la
popularité de michel onfray la télé
l'invite de plus en plus sur les
plateaux il continue de le marteler sa
place elle est du côté du peuple
les convictions politiques anti libérale
clairement à gauche franchement
libertaire à partir du milieu des années
2010 et surtout après janvier 2015 et
l'attentât contre charlie hebdo l'islam
devient une de ses cibles athéistes
convaincu il posait cette question sur
le plateau d'on n'est pas couché
quelques jours après l'attaqué je veux
juste dire que la question qu'on devrait
pouvoir poser sans être assimilé à
marine le pen c est ce qu'il ya une
différence de nature entre un musulman
pacifiste pacifique où est un terroriste
ou une différence de degré ses propos
brouille la frontière entre islam et
islamisme séduisent l'extrême droite
cinq ans plus tard en mai 2000 vingt
nouveaux propos taxés d'islamophobie
dans causeur magazine classé à l'extrême
droite il déclare que l'islam est une
religion à combattre l'islam revendique
clairement l'universalisation de sa
doctrine et comme je ne suis pas
antisémite homophobe misogyne
phallocrate belliciste des valeurs selon
nombre de sourates du coran il est en
effet plus à craindre juin 2020 michel
onfray dans sa revue souverainiste front
populaire parmi les contributeurs le
maire de béziers robert ménard ou encore
le très conservateur philippe de
villiers une initiative s'est lui aussi
sur twitter par marine le pen et
pourtant on frais ne cesse de le
rappeler c'est un homme de gauche
[Musique]